[Music]  I'm gonna fight you I'm sorry what  parking lot after school it's all did  you don't fight I want everybody to see  this  [Applause]  hashtag teacher fight coos no it's not  this  I don't need to be liked I need to  educate  I just don't know the first thing about  fighting Megaforce are you serious just  of 1700s about no running whose you  sleep this game flex my imp lexing  there's nothing there I just take a  punch and then just go down  play dead like possums do or anything  that's like a like a [ __ ] animal  there's a crazy guy at my high school  he's trying to beat me up if you have a  problem with a bully I need you to speak  to a teacher I am a teacher  your goal may not gonna take the dance  you're Robert goddamn charity associate  who's got this thing all lined up what  associate [ __ ] steak small you still hit  like your [ __ ]